the present you is Brave the present you  is hopeful the present you is innovative  and resourceful so I truly believe the  future you has to be a you that loves  otherwise it will cease to flourish you  may use your power  to build walls  and keep people outside or you may use  it to break barriers and welcome them in  you may fill the up your oceans  callously and cut down all the forests  you can destroy the ecology or tend to  them with love  and regenerate life from the waters  increase  you may land on Mars and build armed  City Rules  or you may look for life forms and  species to learn from and respect the  future you  is an infinite you a youth that returns  back  to the original innocence of humanity  which loves from the purity of heart  which which dreams from the clarity of  an untampered mind